welcome back to Las Vegas now we are
winning with the Dew twins the DJ Duo
has been full-time DJ since only 2015
and already on the biggest stages around
the world including their very own win
nightlife residency so welcome ladies
you are officially a part of Las Vegas
not family
you got the DJ sound that's the fact you
guys are very familiar with that yeah we
always got one use that one okay now I'm
gonna have you both introduce yourselves
I'm Bridget you're Bridget I'm Jamie
you're Jamie and obviously the way you
can you know tell the tell the
difference is the hair oh yeah because
other than that identical exactly
beautiful I love it okay let's talk
about where you guys started and how you
became DJs well first of all we're born
and raised in Los Angeles
uh we do everything together including
DJ and producing music we got our start
by interning for a music producer when
we were 18. and at the same time had
just been hired to work in a nightclub
so we were watching how records were
made and then hearing them being played
all night long and it was so inspiring
to us I can imagine how all of that
inspired you guys to become DJs but how
did it Inspire your sound what's your
sound that's a Duo our sound I would say
that we are open format okay as far as
production and when we play like you'll
hear top 40 hip-hop trap EDM house like
you name it we're playing it if it's
good music we're playing it I love it I
love it if it's a Vibe that's for you
absolutely okay now you guys have played
all around the world but what does Vegas
and the win residency mean to you guys
uh we started our residency with the win
in 2021 it's 2022 so this is our second
year with them it's been a dream come
true it's everything you can imagine it
would be and more
um and what's really exciting about the
win is you never know who's going to
show up like last weekend we played the
UFC after party and there was nine major
Fighters that just showed up so you
never know who's there listening to your
music that's the beauty of the win oh
yeah it's just it's where to be it's
where everyone is it's the place to be
on the show it's the best party right so
how can people catch you guys this
weekend
um tonight we're playing at Encore Beach
Club night swim and we'll be back July
15th yep and every weekend after that I
love how you guys play on each other and
we just finish each other she doesn't
forget to share some key information
also as identical twins like we do say
the same things at the same time like
people always ask us that do you guys
think the same talk the same yes we are
constantly finishing each other
sentences I think two is better than one
anyway I agree you guys are awesome
thank you so much you can find out more
of course at winnightlife.com find out
where where you guys are going to be for
the rest of the summer yeah all right
Jillian I'll send it to you bro